if you were trapped on a desolate island
with a bloodthirsty killer what would
you do someone is murdering all of your
classmates and only you can find out who
it is i'm here to break down the
mistakes made what you should do and how
to beat nana in talentless nana these
students are about to be killed one by
one this green-haired kidnap is the most
untalented kid in his class however he's
hiding a powerful secret his classroom
was transported to an island in the
middle of nowhere to train for
humanity's biggest threat these alien
monsters showed up on the planet around
50 years ago and are now even able to
hide amongst us just waiting to strike
these students have been sent to a
desolate island to train for their next
attack the teacher announces that a
transfer student is set to arrive at any
second that's when this pink-haired girl
nana shows up late walking in and
introducing herself to the class she
tells the students that her talent is to
read people's minds the teacher assigns
her to sit next to nanao's desk he
mentions that with all the students
present they need to assign a class
leader nana puts her hands up and
vouches for her new desk neighbor to be
given the position however no one else
agrees the potential leaders decide to
duke it out on the playground and the
teacher gives them permission to begin
fighting they battle it out and throw
down but the long-haired pretty kid
comes out victorious furious the
skinhead throws a gigantic fireball his
way headed straight for the new girl but
nana runs in front of her and blocks the
blast admitting that he does have a
talent of his own neutralizing other
people's talents alright these kids are
supposedly training for the incoming
apocalypse where they'll supposedly
fight an evil known as the enemies of
humanity this girl has been sent by the
government to stop the true enemies of
humanity which the government thinks is
actually these kids but while this whole
ordeal is about to get messy as hell
these kids should have been more
suspicious of what they were training
for to begin with because no one has
actually ever seen an enemy of humanity
which means that all of these kids have
just blindly been training for something
that this institution couldn't even
prove existed to begin with and this
fact makes all these kids gullible as
hell and this is something that this
little turd will take advantage of if
these kids continue to be naive as
they've been but even nana has exhibited
signs of this very trait because proving
someone is an enemy by showing them a
simple kill count number on a phone to
signify their threat level is some
highly gullible bs and this kill count
number seems to be relying on nothing
more than purely theoretical speculation
rather than field-grade analytics and
this agency that controls nana doesn't
even seem to have any hard evidence to
back up how they know these kids are
capable of what they say they are
basically everyone stuck on this island
is as dumb as wilson and we sure as crap
aren't tom hanks after school nanao and
nana meet up and he gives her more
details about his abilities he can
disable users abilities however he can't
neutralize talent users with psychic
abilities the two then hold hands and
nana realizes that she can no longer
read minds suddenly she pulls nanao over
the cliff's side he manages to grab a
conveniently placed hanging rope and
looks at her shocked she tells him that
the students are the real enemies of
humanity and she'll do anything in her
power to kill them all okay the only
thing the now can do to survive is to do
a perfect feet first dive into the water
and swim to shore even that is risky
because the current could very well pull
or push him to the cliff face and then
suck him under water and drown him
anyways the drop from the top of the
cliff edge is about 180 feet meaning the
now is falling from a height similar to
niagara falls cliff divers have
successfully made jumps from 100 plus
feet before and survived even higher
jumps and there are also real-life
examples of people successfully
surviving niagara falls in order to
maximize his chances and before he loses
his grip nanal must make sure he falls
feet first cross his legs at the ankles
and clutch them together tightly the
last thing he wants would be to have a
high velocity seawater enema or have his
legs dislocated when forced into a full
split by the impact of hitting the water
he must cross one arm across the chest
and clutch his elbow tightly to the
chest with the other hand covering the
mouth and the nose heightly with the
hand the sea is going to be cold and by
reflex he'll want to suck in a breath
when he gets dunked in the cold water
you do not want to suck in a breath
until you get back to the surface he's
going to go deep he's got to sit tight
until he quits falling down once his
momentum slows down he has to follow the
bubbles to get back up to the surface if
it is too dark to see the bubbles he has
to hold his breath and drift up until he
can see sunlight he doesn't want to be
swimming for the bottom thinking he's
headed for air the next day nanao has
gone missing and no one knows what
happened to him nana has lunch with this
kid who explains his powers as being
able to go back in time but then the
other student who showed up along with
nana kyoya here interrupts their
conversation to tell nana that he saw
her and the now leaving school together
yesterday and she's been acting very
suspicious kyoya then leaves the room
and the time traveling student urges her
to come along and try to find their
missing classmate they visit the dorms
and the student goes back in time for a
split second he falls to the floor
drained but decides to try again this
time he spots both her and the now
walking out of the school they change
locations and check out the cleft side
the time traveler uses his talent again
disappearing and reappearing in a flash
this time though he mentions he made eye
contact with nana's past self forcing
him to return back to the present
revealing that this is one of his
talents limitations that night nana
knocks on the time traveler's door and
tells him that he missed some vital
information she brings him to the forest
and tells him that they in fact were
chased by an enemy of humanity and nana
was too scared to say anything before
and now was eaten alive and she was
forced to run away nana begs him to go
back into the past and change what
happened but this girl is one evil mofo
and the time traveler transports back
only to drown in the past okay this is
crazy and now we know that nana is up to
no good nana saw him use his power to
punch skinhead but she didn't remember
seeing the time traveler himself
standing up and punching him just the
aftermath but the problem is is that
this time traveler can travel through
time but not space because while you'd
think he would have traveled into the
past and appeared in the same spot as he
was standing in this was not the case in
reality because when the time traveler
went back he mentioned seeing nana
walking with nanao and nana's past
memories were overwritten to remember
seeing him and which caused him to zap
back into the present and all this
happened with him disappearing and
reappearing in the exact same position
but during the final bit where this time
traveler dude disappeared he disappeared
above the lake and this was as clear
clearest day that he was standing above
the lake yet when he came back he
somehow reappeared below the lake which
if we go with what we saw on how his
powers worked from before it's strange
and doesn't make sense how he time
traveled back but this time reappeared
in a different spot than the spot he was
standing from before now it's possible
that the topography and spatial plane is
something that time traveler has to
consciously account for and something
that is not a given within his power
skill set if this is the case though
then this could mean that every time he
jumped he would have had to picture from
beforehand where he would end up in
relation to where his body came from
something along the lines that
nightcrawler would have had to do from
before each jump visually picture where
he would end up beforehand in order to
avoid the possibility of teleporting
right into a wall also we heard that
time traveler's abilities were affected
after each time jump and made him tired
this could mean that after numerous time
jumps his ability to plan his spatial
landing was affected and instead of
landing simply from where he left from
above the lake due to his extreme
fatigue he could have misjumped and
landed below the lake itself causing his
death and while this theory is a little
suspicious it's not suspicious enough
that it couldn't be plausible the fact
however is is that this kid should have
taken better precautionary measures with
a girl that he was already suspicious of
to begin with this kid has the power to
go back in time however the main problem
with traveling backwards in time which
at this point is thought to be
impossible due to something known as the
grandfather paradox and comes from the
idea that if a person travels to a time
before their grandfather had children
and killed that same person that act
would make their very own birth
impossible to begin with but according
to some physicists this problem can be
avoided by something called the novikovi
self-consistency principle which is a
theory on paper at least that would
allow for such a paradox to happen
meaning you could in fact go back in
time and be able to change the course of
history but rather than alter the
present you could simply create another
timeline that would never interfere with
the current timeline you just came from
this is called the many worlds
interpretation meaning that there is a
possibility that the time traveler kid
in fact may never have been able to
alter the present and may in fact exist
in an entirely different separate
timeline in the past and the fact that
the strongest talented users so far on
the island have evolved out of traumatic
experiences makes me think that he could
have used his talent one more time out
of panic since he couldn't swim he could
have actually still been alive and
resided in an entirely separate timeline
this is how insane this kid's powers
were and the fact that nana tricked him
makes this guy an idiot and everyone in
this school here so dang gullible the
next day the students begin to wonder
where their two missing classmates have
gone nana follows kyoya into the hallway
and he asks her to hang out they meet at
his dorm room and he brings her in to
reveal a massive collection of video
games and just before when nana wants to
leave he tells her that he found nanal's
watch kyoya brings her to the cliffside
and asks about where she was during her
first night on the island nanao has been
missing since that date and no trace of
him has been found until now he shows
the broken watch and points to the time
being stuck around 6 pm however kyoya
admits that she's too innocent to be the
one responsible for what happened the
next day they visit their teacher to
discuss what they can do about the
missing students and he tells them that
there's no outside communication until
the graduation date in the hallway kyoya
begins to notice something is off about
nana he checks the storage room outside
to feed the cat finding the place empty
and pours milk onto a pan he then turns
on the stove when suddenly it blows up
into flames nana finds his crispy body
outside and rushes to find help he grabs
her leg before she can leave and reveals
his special ability he's invincible
however he has lost his sense of smell
because of this incredible power well
that's so unfair the next day nana
begins to realize that people are
getting suspicious yeah you think this
shy girl mitchuru notices a mark on her
leg and kneels down to lick her wounds
she thanks her for the kind of gesture
however this shy girl isn't as nice as
she seems nana looks her up on her phone
and finds out that the girl's kill
potential reaches over 150 000 people
nana finds her outside and reveals that
her classmates have set her up on a fake
date they run off and she thanks nana
for having her back that night nana
opens her front door to find kyoya
sitting outside he asks her if he can
come in but gets rejected instantly
finding it strange that nana was going
somewhere late at night after he hears a
cry in the hallway and runs to michiru's
room finding nana lying on the floor
wounded michirou blames the attack on
the enemies of humanity and the other
students rush in to see what's going on
the next day kyoya presses the subject
on last night's incident nana explains
that she hurt enemies coming from
michiru's room being invincible he
questions why she didn't bring him along
he also tells nana that the monster
should have been too strong for a small
group of students to make it run away
kyoya then begins to suspect the evil
girl even more and that's when mitraru
suggests that nana becomes the new
leader of their classroom okay nana is
one sneaky mofo and her inserting
herself into becoming the leader of the
group is one of the smartest things to
do she'll essentially be spearheading
the operation and hunting down the
enemies of humanity while she
simultaneously causes all of this crap
to happen to begin with but this means
that kyoya should have been even more
suspicious of nana because this is not
the first time that she's been found out
at the crime scene and her power means
that she is the only one who can hear
when trouble is nearby but up until now
has coincidentally been unable to hear
any crime until after it happens
interesting i mean if it walks like a
duck talks like a duck and looks like a
duck chances are it's probably a duck
nana up until now has had way too many
coincidences with all of these deaths
and while they may seem random when put
all together they make for a pretty
compelling case this is why kyoya should
have investigated further by spending
more time with nana because the one
mistake he made up until now has been to
leave her alone without figuring out
what she is truly capable of and i mean
knowing your enemy is the first step
towards defeating your enemy which is
why i would not only spend the day with
nana i would pester her every single day
to figure out just what exactly is her
powers what her limits are and her
weaknesses does it tire her out to
read minds once we figure out her
limitations we'll be better able to
piece together if and what she could be
able to do and which will give us a
better chance to figure out and prove
that she is lying to us and everyone
here because the problem with nana's
powers unlike the fire guy's powers for
example is that her power doesn't
involve any perceivable change within
her surrounding environment which means
that for all we know she could simply be
lying about her mind powers
i mean it could be real because we can't
actually see if she's doing what she's
been saying she's been doing and that is
a problem the entire classroom then
agrees to let nana be the new leader of
the group but kyoya notices something is
off regarding the stab wound at home
kyoya begins to theorize that the girl
intentionally hurt herself knowing that
mijiru would heal her wounds however he
can't seem to find a reason why the girl
would be trying to kill his entire
classroom outside of the dorms this
student approaches donna and tells her
that he's discovered something strange
about the girl the student reveals that
he can see into the future and whips out
a photograph showing nana killing him
they sit down at the cafeteria to sort
out their problems and the future seeing
kid explains that whatever he sees in
his future photographs will happen with
100
accuracy suddenly he brings out a photo
of her killing the now that night the
future seeing kid blackmails her into
giving him a back massage like a dirty
bastard they sleep in the same room
overnight and he wakes up to another
surprise from nana he explains that
during his sleep five photos will come
from this camera that will predict the
future however he's only got four in his
possession he checks nana's clothes to
find a photo showing nana dead on the
ground she freaks out and the man makes
a deal with her he's going to hide in
the pe shed overnight and see if the
photo will come true okay this is insane
and what just happened proved that nana
is more of a devious little turd blossom
than we thought however this future
seeing kid should have known that
someone who had the guts to come to a
superhero filled island and begin
killing people would have been a little
more cunning than your average little
bird the fact that the matter is that
this kid knew who nana really was when
she first came to the island and
blackmailing her into becoming his
girlfriend was a bad move however this
kid's power is very passive and limited
in scope therefore he should have
realized that nana would have used his
camera to play a trick on him i mean
it's not that hard to put two and two
together in fact i'm more surprised than
no one has tried to pull that trick on
him before also already knowing the
limitations of his powers means that he
should have thought that someone could
have potentially shown him a fake
picture of the future since clearly the
photos that showed the future looked
identical to any polaroid photo shot
which means that this was his weakness
and one he should have known to look out
for beforehand also none in the picture
is shown to die by ligature
strangulation which in reality would
have been a lot more difficult to do and
would have taken a lot longer to die
which can take anywhere from 1 to 15
minutes this should have at the very
least arised some suspicions within him
because if someone was choosing to kill
someone by choking them they would have
likely opted to use their hands or
something more sturdy than a jumping
rope also the one thing he had going for
him is that this picture showed the
exact location of where the future
incident was going to take place this
meant he shouldn't have been so
willingly gone to the location to tempt
fate as albert einstein once said the
distinction between past present and
future is only a stubbornly persistent
illusion because even if the future in
theory was already written just like the
grandfather paradox the future just like
trying to change the past would result
in countless possible outcomes as to how
the future would unfold since the future
hasn't happened yet meaning it can
happen in one of many ways and this kid
should have at least suspected that his
premonitions were possible outcomes not
absolute truths as he claims in knowing
this possibility this could have allowed
the kid to realize that he actually had
all the time in the world and should not
have rushed to the shed to begin with
rather he should have opted to hide in
an entirely different spot like in a
friend's room in a place that was closer
to the main school and its students that
night the future seeing kid walks in and
carelessly sits down not realizing that
nana is about to strike suddenly she
attacks him with the same weapon from
the photograph but the boy manages to
fight her off he pushes her to the
ground and is ready to enjoy his victory
but that's when nana reveals that she's
pricked him with a poison needle when he
grabbed her the boy falls to the ground
and she explains that the photo of her
dying was fate however she still took
one of his five photos from the night
before that's when the lights turn on to
reveal what the stolen photo really was
and then michiru and kyoya walk in to
find nana caught red-handed realizing
that she's going to be found out she
begs michiru to fix the boy up asap she
admits that the future seeing kid was
blackmailing her showing her
embarrassing photos from the future to
pretend that they were going out she
blames the boy's current state on a
medical condition or from the invisible
enemies of humanity a few hours later
michiru realizes that her talent is
beginning to make her tired she rubs his
back and finds a photo inside his shirt
suddenly nana appears and questions what
she's looking at michiru hands over the
photo wondering what the hell she just
saw nana lies and says that the boy's
future predictions only show what he's
seeing in his dreams the next day the
class attends the boy's funeral the
principal complains about there being no
police on the island and kyoya
interrupts to voice his suspicions he
demands an autopsy when suddenly the
coffin begins shaking and the boy comes
back to life this short kid walks in and
reveals his talent is to be able to
reanimate dead bodies he tells them that
the corpse will tell everyone his cause
of death if the body remembers okay
kyoya now has one of the most important
assets on this island and that is this
kid because up until now his gut has
told him who the real killer on this
island is and despite conveniently
looking innocent and kind of dumb kyoya
knows that nana's whereabouts during all
the murders are too much of a
coincidence but what this guy needs just
like in real life court cases is the
evidence that directly connects nana's
dirty hands with all the murders that
have taken place so far however it's odd
that despite the piles of bodies growing
over the last few days that kyoya hasn't
already started using the school's
children to his advantage because
remember we're at a super powered school
which means that it's not out of this
world to assume that the school is full
of super-powered kids and would likely
have class records detailing just
exactly what their powers all are and
kyoya clearly being all pally with the
teacher earlier means that he could have
easily snuck in and got some access to
get his hands on those very important
records this means that all this time
instead of whining and pouting about
nana being the killer he should have
just started looking into all the kids
powers that he could have better used to
help him find out the killer's identity
if he did this from the start and go an
all lone wolf detective then he could
have found out about this necromancer
kids abilities from the very beginning
kyoya wants to get to the bottom of this
but everyone here says that reviving
this corpse is too disrespectful and no
one here is about to let him [ __ ] on
this corpse kyoya then has no choice and
his investigation into who killed this
kid ends right here that night nana is
in the short kid's room while he sleeps
and she sticks a needle into the boy's
neck injecting poison into his body she
moves to his girlfriend's room and gets
ready to inject another needle when
suddenly the short kid attacks and holds
her down the girlfriend reveals that she
is the true necromancer and that her
boyfriend is actually already dead
knowing that the girlfriend is having
relationship troubles she promises to
tell what the short kid is thinking if
they let her up the girl obliges and
nana runs away she escapes the dorm and
rushes into the forest necromancy chick
and her boyfriend chase her down looking
around and in the bushes for any sight
of her suddenly she pops out trying to
grab the girl's necklace but her
boyfriend is about to attack her so she
pushes the girlfriend over they chase
her deeper into the forest and nana is
suddenly ambushed by more corpses she
runs into a broken shelter and begins
fixing it up but they find her and she
runs inside to block the door thinking
she's safe and begins to set a trap but
necromancy chick already has a trap of
her own asking nana didn't you check
under the bed suddenly three corpses
jump out and attack her pinning her to
the ground but fortunately for her the
sun has risen freezing the corpses in
their tracks necromancy girlfriend here
tells her that the reanimated corpses
can still move as long as the light
doesn't reach them
okay this twist is shockingly delicious
but this chick could have been more
careful and methodical from the jump so
far from what we've seen of this
necromancer unlike nana this chick lacks
a killing spirit and this battle was
uneven from the start because despite
her powers and nana's seemingly lack of
any powers nana seems to be the only one
on this island that truly possesses a
murderer's mentality the necromancer
chick from the get-go should have at the
very least been more guarded and if she
couldn't bring herself to kill nana she
should have incapacitated her by
breaking her legs or something because
this lack of foresight will come back to
bite her now like most people this
necromancer chick probably had some
concept of time passing and therefore
should have used this to her advantage
chasing nana right before sunrise
knowing that her power stopped working
technically during the day meant that
she should have verbally stated to nana
that she would give her a 12 hour head
start to leave the island before
evacuating the premises with all of her
corpse friends all of this should have
been done before the sun rose this could
have kept up the illusion that her
powers had no limits in theory and did
not expire at sunrise the fact that this
necromancy chick willingly admitted her
weakness too was beyond dumb and the
same thing with the future seeing kid
these kids have been way too willing to
reveal the limitations of their powers
like dang what are you doing stop doing
that and a necromancy chick locks a
wounded nana inside 24 hours later she
comes back to the shelter where nana's
staying finding it completely empty she
sends her corpses out to search for her
and heads back to the dorms but that's
when nana surprises them and pushes them
both over and takes a slip of paper from
her back pocket she brings them to the
cliff side and threatens to drop the
piece of paper into the ocean if the
item disappears then the girlfriend can
no longer touch it to reanimate her
short dead boyfriend suddenly she
poisoned the girl and drops the piece of
paper into the ocean nana disposes of
the bodies and then finds michirus bully
in the forest she distracts the girl and
poisons her while she's not looking
telling her that she'll provide the
antidote in exchange for the girl's
phone she agrees and hands it over but
nana opens up her other hand revealing
that there was never any medicine
allowing the girl to die on the ground
the next day kyoyo questions her about
the missing students she admits that
they're all dead and brings the class
with her to see their corpses she blames
the short kid's death on his girlfriend
claiming that she tripped off of the
cliff to her death she politely asks the
skinhead to burn the corpses along with
the others in the forest in order to
give the dead a sense of dignity and
closure yeah right okay i got a cold
bullcrap on what nana is saying right
now because this is so suspicious up
until now she has literally been
coincidentally unaccounted for during
all of the murders that have happened so
far but the problem is even with all of
the coincidences in the world unless we
can directly link nana to all of this we
have nothing because in a court of law
the presumption of innocence is a legal
principle that states everyone is
innocent until proven guilty and to top
it off nana comes off as so freaking
cute and adorable to the point that she
is still our leader and this means that
just like trying to make someone look
guilty in front of a sympathetic jury
this is going to be an uphill battle
because no one here is on our side to
begin with and the perception of nana's
character means that everyone will find
any compelling coincidences or evidence
that we find against nana to be just
hearsay at best unless we catch her
directly in the act this means that we
have two options really we'll either
need to catch nana or whoever the real
killer is dead to rights in the middle
of the next murder or we need to make it
so increasingly difficult to the point
to kill where the effort to go through
with any more murders won't be worth the
amount of pressure we're putting on for
the last part i would say now that even
if we have no outside help coming to the
island we need to start taking proactive
measures starting with changing how the
school operates since we don't have
anything on nana i would focus more on
scaring the crap out of everyone and
make everyone here scared for their
lives because why the heck is everyone
here so chill about all of these deaths
because just like hitler's successful
fear-mongering tactics in world war ii
you need to grab everyone's attention
first in order to get them to do what
you want according to evolutionary
psychology humans have a strong impulse
to pay attention to danger because of
our inclination to survive as a species
throughout our evolutionary history so
we need to take a play right out of
adolf's playbook and use the concept of
fear or more specifically highlight the
threat of a murderer being on campus to
our advantage scare the public scare the
students we'll be able to inform them of
the reality of the situation and from
then on get them to do what we want such
as for starters changing the rooms and
areas that people sleep and converse in
if we can get everyone to sleep in the
halls where everybody is present and
accounted for this will be one method
that we can use to exponentially make
the killer's next few steps all the more
difficult and this is just one tactic
that we need to start using to slow all
of these murders down from here on out
we'll be able to buy time and figure out
our next move and or catch nana i mean
the murderer in the act itself outside
of the dorm rooms kyoya leaves the
students with a simple realization nana
disappears every time someone is
murdered suddenly they hear a scream
from inside the building and rushes in
to witness a deadly sight another
student is dead in her room they check
her phone and kyoya blames the whole
incident on nana the other classmates
then rush in and demand him to explain
what's going on he then says that nana
brutally killed poison girl and left her
friend's contacts spiked with poison and
in doing so she makes sure that
teleportation girl will never be able to
find her friend he then explains that he
already knew that the girl has to eat
raw animals from the forest and finds it
suspicious that nana was in the exact
same location kyoya then exposes her for
wanting to burn the corpses and tells
her the evidence speaks for itself she
took the girl's phone and texted her
friend informing her that the contacts
were going to be returned kyoya then
checks her clothes but finds no evidence
to prove her guilty he then demands to
take care of the corpse until morning
and agrees to report the incident to the
head office later in the night michirou
finds nana sitting outside of the dorm
room nana asks her what she's doing and
she responds by saying that she's
patrolling for enemies when suddenly
michirou pulls a knife to her throat
nana pushes the knife away and demands
to know what's going on mijuru says she
knows she's a bloodthirsty killer and
it's only a matter of time until she
gets caught that's when their classmates
interrupt and michirou goes back inside
the next day they meet up on the
cliffside nada confronts her about being
a fake michiru the girl admits that she
isn't the original and reveals himself
as the ex-student jin he explains that
he's here to make a deal and takes her
back to his hideout the ex-student makes
them drinks and explains that he's been
on the island for five years since all
of his classmates killed each other he
says that he managed to escape the
island with his ability to shape-shift
into any living being and flew off of
the island however his own grandmother
refused to believe that he was alive he
then returned to the island to find a
safe haven and figure out the secret
behind this deadly school suddenly the
ex-student begins coughing and nana
reveals that his drink was poisoned she
picks up her phone to call the
higher-ups but then a fake version kyoya
snatches it from behind she tries to run
but jyn then turns into skinhead and
uses his ability to summon up a giant
fireball badly injuring her jin
questions her background and she
explains that her family was killed by
the enemies of humanity the next day the
classmates attend the funeral of another
student kyoya asks the principal to
speak with the higher-ups realizing the
situation is becoming more and more
suspicious he then finds both nana and
michiru hanging out in the morning
demanding that they follow him somewhere
he then reveals another deadly murder
however nana realizes that it wasn't her
doing and the dead guy's green-haired
girlfriend admits that she was the one
who found the body the girlfriend brings
everyone outside and uses her ability on
kyoya that night the principal knocks on
nana's door later in the night to hand
over her missing uniform she thanks him
and realizes that the poison vile hidden
inside is gone kyoya interrupts to say
that he's going to be interrogating the
girlfriend that's when the principal
mentions that the higher-ups from the
mainland will soon be visiting him and
nana questioned the girlfriend on the
incident they then discuss what was said
in the hallway and kyoyo determines her
to be the killer he suspects that the
couple had a fight beforehand and that
the girl went crazy killing him and
using her ability to cover up any
evidence alright if i'm kyoya this event
will only make our jobs that much harder
because now what we have here is two
loose threads in a very messy web of
conflicting lies this girl has the
ability to basically control and
manipulate the pressure out of air she
can also create lethal air blades that
as we saw you wouldn't want to mess with
she's basically like a little discount
airbender like aang or aung if you mess
with m night shyamalan's airbender
version i pity you if that's the case
but regardless something is off here
because the body was found by the
green-haired girlfriend in the morning
but the corpse has clearly been here for
a few hours meaning this poor little
dude died at night but if this is the
case again we gotta ask i did the group
of boys next door didn't hear anything
now there is a very obvious possibility
that they could all be in on it but this
seems unlikely and judging from their
character and demeanor i doubt this now
even though this isn't considered a
human ability it might as well be
because on average human screams can be
loud as hell going near as 100 decibels
in volume and for comparison the sound
of a whisper is around 30 decibels a
normal conversation is 60 decibels and a
motorcycle running about is about 95
decibels and depending on the wall a
conversation of about 40 decibels will
be able to be heard the average wall
thickness in japan is about 9.8 inches
thick which would be considered quite
thin in something in comparison to the
average wall thickness of a skyscraper
over in the west such as in australia
where the thickness of their walls tend
to be around 19 inches but in general
the makeup of interior walls will
feature several layers of wall types and
thicknesses which will consist of
sheathing siding wall boards and
finishes including air gaps and so on
this means that the wall thickness for
different structures will vary between
residential walls and the rest however
it seems as though this school walls is
made of much heavier construction
materials such as concrete which will
usually be around 8 to 12 inches thick
and also from the fact that this school
is on an island where the weather could
be more rough leads me to believe that
concrete blocks were the foundation of
the walls and this material is naturally
resistant to extreme temperatures and
has increased thermal insulation
properties and it will not degrade as a
result of ice and thaw making it a
reliable material and one that will be
able to isolate sound very well the
concrete walls here would have likely
been able to absorb some of the energy
that would have come from the
boyfriend's screen however such a screen
produced from the boyfriend at around 90
decibels would have still been able to
be heard at least somewhat by the group
next door if we take into account that
the entrance of the room featured a
wooden door because a standard wooden
door tends to only offer around 20
decibels of sound proofing at around 1.4
inches of width between one side of the
door and the other in short it means
it's impossible that the boys wouldn't
have heard any type of scream also
someone entering a room would have
likely made the victim inside the room
turn around to see who's coming in
because that's what people do when
someone enters a room but if the victim
didn't recognize the killer obviously he
would have either used his power
screamed or there would have been a
noisy commotion of some kind that would
have been heard through the walls and
the door at least a little bit the fact
that the victim didn't scream and had
his back turned here suggests that the
victim knew the killer and let the
killer in before the murderer literally
backstabbed him this makes the
girlfriend super suspicious as hell as
she would have been a very familiar face
and could have killed the boyfriend
after he let her in when he wasn't
looking or the fact that the body due to
rigor mortis setting in after
post-mortem could indicate that the
crime scene happened elsewhere meaning
this kid was killed somewhere else and
brought in here afterwards which could
have also explained why no one heard the
screams to begin with and if that's the
case this still would have made the
girlfriend my primary suspect and not
nana at least in this case if i'm kyoya
then the one thing i would start working
on is the motive behind it and this will
likely explain the reasoning which will
either make the girlfriend look more
guilty or more innocent which could
benefit us by narrowing down the suspect
list either way the motive behind the
girlfriend is the one thing i would
begin focusing on and this will help
inform everything else later jyn finds
her looking through michirou's diary he
hands over a poison vial that she left
behind and tells her that mijuru has
been in the shower for far too long she
goes into the bathroom and sees her
passed out in the tub she then takes the
exhausted girl to bed and notices that
she's suffering from a strange illness
she then brings kyoya to help but he
can't seem to find out what's wrong
later the girlfriend visits and asks her
how michiroo got injured that's when
nana realizes that something is clearly
off that night jyn visits to inform her
that he spotted michiru walking out
extremely late he then mentions that the
girl said she was called by somebody but
doesn't know who nana chases after her
missing friend and finds her injured in
the forest she then jumps in front of
the unknown killer's attack severely
injuring herself and that's when nana
realizes that she knows exactly who the
culprit is one of the students that has
the talent to leave his physical body
and kill that student she turns around
to find out that the killer is the
blonde kid kento he then stabs nana one
more time and she begs michiru to stay
away and just when all hope is lost the
ghost version of himself begins to lose
consciousness as kyoya chokes him in the
bathroom stall stopping him from
attacking however nana is fatally
wounded with only minutes before death
that's when michiru comes back and
begins to heal the injured nana nana
wakes up with her life saved but she
looks over to see that her friend is
dead meaning that she can now mark off
another kill off of her kill list but
what do you think about talentless nana
would you be able to survive let us know
what you like and what you didn't like
about the video don't forget to leave a
thumbs up subscribe don't forget to
check out our playlist and also we're
going to be at the anime expo july 1st
to the 4th come say hi if you see us i
promise we're nice maybe